en este vídeo tenemos tres fracciones
dos tercios por siete octavos ocho
séptimos por dos tercios y cinco por dos
entre tres por cinco lo que quiero que
hagas en este vídeo es pensar en estas
tres fracciones y ver cuál de ellas es
más grande cuál es la que está en medium
y cuál es la más pequeña de estas tres y
para esto te recomiendo que no hagas la
multiplicación de las fracciones y mejor
observes bien cómo está el problema para
que tú intente resolver este acertijo
así que te recomiendo que pausa es justo
ahorita el vídeo para que tú lo intentes
por ti mismo
ahora bien si ya pausa este el vídeo y
lo encuentra es la solución te voy a dar
una pista para ver si así se te hace más
fácil encontrar la solución lo que
quiero que veas es que en estas tres
fracciones estamos multiplicando por dos
tercios aquí tengo dos tercios que
multiplica a siete octavos aquí tengo
ocho séptimos que multiplica a dos
tercios ok y aquí tengo cinco por dos
entre tres por cinco y de una manera un
poco escondida tengo también metido aquí
a la fracción dos tercios es decir que
esta fracción de aquí y vamos a escribir
la de una vez la podemos ver de la
siguiente manera esta fracción de aquí
es exactamente lo mismo que 5 por 2
entre 5 por 3 ok lo único que hice fue
cambiar de lugar a estos dos y esto es
exactamente lo mismo que cinco quintos
que multiplica su vez a dos tercios y
que está otra vez el dos tercios el dos
tercios que nosotros estábamos buscando
así que si te das cuenta
estas tres fracciones tienen que ver con
la fracción dos tercios si no has
encontrado la solución igual y con esta
pista puedes hallar de una manera mucho
más rápida así que te voy a recomendar
que de nuevo pausa el vídeo e intentes
buscar la solución
muy bien ahora vamos a intentar resolver
este problema para que veas aquí tenemos
dos tercios por siete octavos aquí
tenemos dos tercios por ocho séptimos y
aquí tenemos cinco quintos por dos
tercios así que qué te parece si dibujo
aquí voy a dibujar aquí un rectángulo
que tenga una altura que tenga una
altura ok de dos tercios vamos a empezar
con una altura de dos tercios porque si
te das cuenta las tres fracciones tienen
que ver con la multiplicación de dos
tercios entonces voy a decir que esta
altura o espera que me fui muy muy mal a
esta altura de aquí esta altura es dos
tercios dos tercios ok y bueno vamos a
fijarnos primero en la fracción que está
a la derecha tengo cinco quintos por dos
tercios ahora si te das cuenta 5 entre 5
es lo mismo que 1 y 1 por dos tercios es
lo mismo que dos tercios así que si
nosotros nos fijamos solamente en la
altura de este rectángulo que tengo aquí
puedo decir que la altura que es dos
tercios la puedo ver como 5 sobre 5 5
sobre 5 qué
aplica a dos tercios que multiplica a
dos tercios porque al final la altura de
este rectángulo se va a mantener igual
esta fracción que tengo aquí esta de
aquí la puedo ver como un rectángulo que
tenga altura dos tercios si me fijo
solamente en la altura ok ahora lo que
voy a hacer es fijarme en que aquí tengo
una unidad por dos tercios y voy a
empezar a buscar una escala con la cual
esta altura se haga más pequeña o más
grande ajustando la con estas fracciones
que tengo aquí si te das cuenta aquí
tengo dos tercios por siete octavos pero
siete octavos es un número más pequeño
que uno por lo tanto realmente lo que
estoy haciendo es a la altura dos
tercios
la estoy multiplicando por algo más
pequeño que uno por lo tanto la estoy
encogiendo cuando multiplico una
cantidad por algo más pequeño que uno
estoy obteniendo algo más pequeño que
esa cantidad siete octavos es más
pequeño que 1 así que está más o menos
por aquí y si yo me fijo ahora en este
rectángulo que tengo de verde este
rectángulo de verde representa
a dos tercios es decir la misma altura
pero multiplicado por un número más
pequeño que 17 octavos por lo tanto
puedo decir que esta altura es dos
tercios dos tercios que multiplica a
siete octavos a siete octavos ok
esta va a ser la altura de este nuevo
rectángulo y ahora si te das cuenta este
rectángulo tiene una altura más pequeña
que este rectángulo de aquí ahora para
finalizar fíjate bien en esta fracción
que tengo aquí 8 séptimos por dos
tercios 8 séptimos es un valor más
grande que 1 por lo tanto lo que va a
ser al número dos tercios es hacerlo un
poco más grande que su valor que dos
tercios es decir que si yo tuviera un
rectángulo con la altura de dos tercios
cuando lo multiplicó por un número más
grande que uno es lo que estoy haciendo
es que crezca su altura es decir que si
nosotros tenemos aquí este rectángulo
que mide dos tercios de altura bueno
pues un rectángulo de ocho séptimos por
dos tercios es un poquito más grande no
tanto un poquito más grande que esta
altura de dos tercios porque lo estoy
multiplicando por un número que es más
grande que uno
así que déjame hacer este rectángulo por
aquí ok y este rectángulo va a tener
como altura a 8 séptimos 8 séptimos lo
voy a poner aquí 8 entre 7 que
multiplica a 2 tercios que multiplica a
2 tercios
esta es la altura de este rectángulo que
tengo aquí de lujo y ya con esto te
puedes dar cuenta de cómo están las
alturas de estos tres rectángulos y por
lo tanto cómo está la multiplicación de
estas tres fracciones ya podemos
clasificar estas tres fracciones en cuál
es la más grande cual es la de en medio
y cuál es la menor la más grande es 8
séptimos por dos tercios porque tenemos
a la misma cantidad dos tercios
multiplicada por un número más grande
que uno después tendríamos la fracción 5
por 2 entre 5 por 3 que es lo mismo que
cinco quintos por dos tercios que es lo
mismo que un entero por dos tercios es
decir tenemos la cantidad 200 x 1 lo
cual es exactamente lo mismo que dos
tercios esta cantidad quedó justo en
medio porque es la misma cantidad
multiplicada por 1 y para finalizar
podemos concluir que la cantidad más
pequeña esto
por siete octavos porque siete octavos
es un número más pequeño que uno y por
lo tanto aquí tengo a dos tercios
multiplicado por una cantidad más
pequeña que uno lo que hace que se
encoja y entonces me queda la altura de
este rectángulo que tengo aquí lo que
quiere decir que este es el más pequeño
entre estas tres fracciones y es más
pequeño porque estamos multiplicando por
algo más pequeño que 1